the best leaders that i've ever met that
i've ever met have courage courage to do
the right thing courage to stay focused
on that long-term vision encouraged to
withstand the extreme pressures that
they face to meet short-term deadlines i
mean let's face it you know uh wall
street and and the markets and market
forces put pressure on executives to
make decisions that they know are bad
for their company and avoid making
decisions that they know are good for
their company also that you can help
somebody else who works at a an
investment bank make their bonus it has
they don't care how you do
um and so uh when we talk about obeying
the shareholder it's you know we have to
be very careful because we're helping
them them get what they need but they
might be doing it at the expense of our
company um and so i think it it it takes
a lot of a lot of courage to say look if
you believe in our vision and you
believe in our and our uh uh our people
invest in us if you don't don't and we
all know the result which is when you're
doing well they invest in you anyway and
when you're not doing well they don't
invest in you but there are always a
group of investors who do believe in you
and those loyal investors like a loyal
customer are what make company is great
there's one large public company that i
know
where they've done something very
sophisticated where they actually
bifurcated their investor community
where in one group are the investors who
believe in their vision believe in their
executive team when they've been forced
to make difficult decisions sometimes
with short-term losses those investors
have stuck with them have been
encouraging and and and pushed them to
do the right thing
and the other side are those
fair-weathered investors who they don't
really care about you it's all about
them and they push push push push push
for the short-term gains and so when
they say that their shareholder focused
they are but only this group
and they have the courage to ignore that
group i find that quite sophisticated
and much more helpful to stay on that
long visionary path
knowing full well that you can't please
everyone